one of our guests who made a lot of
wealth
creating the trio and the PAMP I ladonna
dibinsky makes the argument that that is
why she is engaged right now she's alive
and she's vibrant in being engaged in
philanthropy and those decisions and
addressing the question of does she do
it on now and spend it all now while she
is here or does she pass it on for some
future generation or her children are
you grappling with that because clearly
there's a benefit for you and Betsy
being engaged right now and being able
to to course-correct and alter and it's
a difference when other people will be
stewarding this if in fact you choose
for other people just doing this to some
point in the future how have you
resolved that yourself we talked about
it quite often and I would say if we had
to make a decision now we would say that
we want to do as much as we can do while
we're alive and we're engaged and that
for us we don't need to leave a legacy
of a foundation that that our family or
other professional people are
administering on our behalf if it turns
out that our children have an interest
in getting engaged in that then that
would be wonderful and at that point in
time it I would suggest that it should
be what their passions are and not
necessarily trying to live out our
passions so for now our feeling is we're
here it gives us great pleasure to be
working with organizations small
nonprofit organizations large nonprofit
organizations and to give as much as we
can of our time and the of our finances
to to make it happen it's a maturing
process for us and then if I see you in
a couple years we may be thinking
differently but a snapshot of today I
think this is what that would I say